We want to create a blueprint pickup and we want to double click the pickup to create
some data and to edit.
First thing we want to do is we want to add a mesh to our pickup.
So I'm going to hit control and space bar to open my quick draw.
I added starter content so we can go to starter content props.
If you don't have starter content installed you could do one of two things.
You could just go to the all content, you could select your filter from here and you
could click static mesh and that will filter all the static meshes in your project so you
can select whichever static mesh you would like.
I'm just going to clear that static mesh filter out because it's always good to remember
to do that just in case you can't find the information you want.
I'm going to go back to the props section and I'm going to say add this statue here
sm underscore statue for my prop.
Again you can add any mesh you would like.
I'm going to go to add the green plus button here and you'll see static mesh and it says
sm statue because I've got the statue selected.
Now if you don't have anything that you can see the file name for there make sure you
select it through that quick draw by pressing control and space bar and selecting it.
So I've got the statue and I'll navigate around there.
Again same navigation tools as you're using with inside of Unreal viewport so right mouse
button to look around, left to go back and forth, both mouse buttons to go up and down.
So we'll add another component this time we'll type box into the search list and I
want to create a box collision.
I'm going to drag this box collision up and on the details panel you'll see box extent
here.
So the box extent I'm just going to make a little bit bigger in Z and I'm going to make
a little bit thicker in Y and a little bit thicker in Z just so it houses the pickup
nicely.
So I'm going to compile, I'm going to save and I'm just going to put this pickup into
my map so I know where it is.
So I'm going to get the pickup window, I'm going to pin it up there for my blueprint,
I'm going to go back into the third person map, I want to select my pickup from the content
browser and just drag it into the scene.
If I look at it there, looks pretty good, the size is okay, that works for me.
So if the size of the asset that you picked isn't correct you can just scale that up by
going back into your blueprint window, selecting that and then selecting the scale of whatever
scale you want that to be, you can change those numbers.
So let's create a basic blueprint script just to pick up this pickup.
So we're going to select the event graph up here, I'm going to navigate to some free
space by right mouse dragging, I'm moving downwards.
I'm going to select our box from the box collision that we added before, I'm going to go back
over to the right hand side of the screen, I'm going to scroll down to the bottom and
you'll see on component begin overlap.
So I'm going to click begin overlap.
So you'll see on component begin overlap and in brackets you'll see box and that is the
box up there.
So I know that that box is talking to this event.
So when I overlap the box, I want something to happen.
So I'm going to drag out, I'm going to type destroy and select destroy actor.
So I just left mouse dragged out, a new menu popped up, I type destroy and you just select
destroy actor.
Now what this is essentially doing is saying I have overlapped this box, now destroy this
entire blueprint.
So I'm going to go to compile at the top left here, I'm going to save, I'm going to go back
into my third person map, I'm going to press the play button, I can see my pickup over
here and it just destroyed as I ran over to it.
So I'll hit escape and press play again, looking at the pickup, I run over to it and as soon
as I hit the box which is surrounding the pickup, it destroys.
And that in essence is the start of your blueprint journey where we can add much more functionality
into a pickup, you could spawn a particle that shows that you picked it up, you could
add a score to the pickup so that the player can start adding score.
From there you can start building these interactive experiences depending on what you want.
Hopefully that was just a useful quick example of what a blueprint can do and the power of them.
Thanks for watching!